>> Judge: WELCOME BACK TO
THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF
HANNITY THE TRUMP AGENDA.
RELATIONS ARE GETTING EVEN
COLDER.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CONDEMNED RUSSIA AGAIN TODAY
AFTER MOSCOW ANNOUNCED THAT
IT WILL EXPEL 60 U.S.
DIPLOMATS AND CLOSE THE U.S.
CONSULATE IN ST. PETERSBURG
IN RETALIATION FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S DECISION TO THEIR
DIPLOMATS AND CLOSE A
RUSSIAN CONSULATE IN
SEATTLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TOUGH
ACTION WAS IN RESPONSE TO
RUSSIA'S SUSPECTED POISONING
OF AN EXSPY AND HIS DAUGHTER
IN GREAT BRITAIN EARLIER
THIS MONTH.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
FOREIGN POLICY ISSUE THE
PRESIDENT IS DEALING WITH
TODAY HE ALSO SPOKE ABOUT
POSSIBLY HOLDING UP A MAJOR
TRADE AGREEMENT WITH SOUTH
KOREA UNTIL THE NUCLEAR
SITUATION IN NORTH KOREA
GETS RESOLVED.
TAKE A LOOK.
I MAY HOLD IT UP UNTIL AFTER
A DEAL IS MADE WITH NORTH
KOREA.
DOES EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND
THAT.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
RIGHT?
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY STRONG
CARD.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE IS TREATED FAIRLY
AND WE'RE MOVING ALONG VERY
NICELY WITH NORTH KOREA.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
CERTAINLY THE RHETORIC HAS
CALMED DOWN JUST A LITTLE
BIT.
WOULDN'T YOU SAY?
WOULD YOU SAY?
AND WE WILL SEE HOW IT ALL
TURNS DOWN.
MAYBE IT WILL BE GOOD.
MAYBE IT WON'T.
AND IF IT'S NO GOOD WE ARE
WALKING.
AND IF IT'S GOOD WE WILL
EMBRACE IT.
>> Judge: JOINING US NOW, HE
IS A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
FORECLOSURE AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE FLORIDA
CONGRESSMAN RON DESANTIS.
ALSO JOINING US ALLEN WEST.
THE RHETORIC IS CLAMPING
DOWN A BIT U THAT'S ALL
GOOD.
WE ARE NOT HEARING ABOUT
ROCKET MAN AND ALL THE OTHER
STUFF.
FROM ROCKET MAN.
SO, I WILL START WITH YOU,
CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS.
YOU KNOW, YOU SIT ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT WE HAVE GOT TODAY WITH
THE EXPULSION OF, YOU KNOW,
THE RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS AND
THEN THEIR RETALIATION OR
TIT-FOR-TAT, ALTHOUGH THE
ISSUE IS THAT WE HAD A
REASON FOR THE TAT.
IT WAS THE BRITISH SPY WHO
WAS POISONED ON THE U.K.
GROUNDS.
HIS DAUGHTER I UNDERSTAND IS
STILL ALIVE.
BUT IS GETTING BETTER.
THEY HAD NO REASON, OTHER
THAN RETALIATION.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU
ABOUT RUSSIA AND THE UNITED
STATES?
>> WELL, IT HE WILL ITS ME
THAT UNDER
MEAT UNDER
ME - UNDER
ME --UNDER
ME -- IDER
ME -- ITER
ME -- IT HE WILLS ME UNDER HE
ME -- IT HE WILLS ME UN IR HE
ME -- IT HE WILLS ME UN IT HE
ME -- IT HE WILLS ME UN IT TELLS
ME -- IT HE WILLS ME UN IT TELLM
ME -- IT HE WILLS ME UN IT TELL.
VERY FIRM.
THEY TRIED TO RESET.
THEY DID NOTHING WHEN RUSSIA
INVADED CRIMIA, MADE
INCURSIONS INTO UKRAINE.
WENT INTO SYRIA.
WHAT HAS THIS PRESIDENT
DONE, DONALD TRUMP SINCE HE
HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
HE HAS PROVIDED LETHAL AID
TO UKRAINE SO THEY COULD
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
OBAMA WOULDN'T DO THAT
PROVIDED MISSILES TO POLAND
SO THEY COULD DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
HE STRUCK ASSAD IN SYRIA
WHICH OBAMA WOULDN'T DO AND
FORCED THE RED LINE.
AND REALLY COMMITTED TO YOU
EXPANDING AMERICA'S OIL AND
GAS CAPABILITY.
RUSSIA, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS BUT THEY ARE
A BIG GAS STATION AND TO THE
EXTENT WE ARE CHALLENGING
THEM WITH EXPORTS TO EUROPE,
THAT'S GOING TO WEAKEN
PUTIN.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT THAT'S
BEEN STRONG AGAINST RUSSIA.
SCUJ JUDGE COLONEL ALLEN
WEST, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
COLD WAR AND THERE IS TALK
NOW THAT WE MAY BE ENTERING
INTO A NEW PHASE, WHICH IS
ALMOST IRONIC, GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THE DEMOCRATS KEEP
SAYING THAT THE TRUMP TEAM
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA AND
AFTER 15 MONTHS THEY HAVE
COME UP WITH ZILCH.
DO YOU THINK WE ARE ENTERING
A NEW COLD WAR ERA.
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT, JUDGE.
WE ARE GETTING THERE WHEN
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS ASKED
ABOUT THE GREATEST THE
COLLAPSE OF THE SOVIET
UNION.
TRYING TO REESTABLISH THAT
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGM
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGN
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGC
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGD
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGM
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGN
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEGE
RUSSIAN MEMBERS OF THE JURY HEG.
LITHUANIA AND ASTONE I
CAN'T, CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS
HAS TALKED ABOUT THE THREATS
HE HAS MADE WITH CRIMEA AND
UKRAINE.
HE HAS DONE THAT BECAUSE HE
HAS NOT SEEN A VERY STRONG
POLICY.
YOU ARE STUARTING TO SEE
THAT TYPE OF STRONG POLICY
AND WITH THE ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT JOHN BOLTON IS GOING TO
BE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, I DON'T THINK YOU
WILL GET THE SAME TYPE OF
WEAK AND FECKLESS ADVICE
THAT A SUSAN RICE WAS GIVING
TO PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
>> Judge: RON, YOU ARE
NODDING YOUR HEAD.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, JOHN
BOLTON, IT'S A VERY STRONG
VOICE, VERY CLEAR THINKER.
AND I THINK THAT IMPORTANTLY
HE KNOWS HOW TOUT
BUREAUCRACY WORKS AND SO HE
IS GOING TO BE INSTRUMENTAL
IN GETTING THE BUREAUCRATS
TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POLICIES
WHICH THEY HAVEN'T BEEN, YOU
KNOW, AS WILLING TO DO AS
THEY WERE UNDER OBAMA.
I THINK IT WAS A REALLY GOOD
CHOICE AND I DO THINK THAT
YOU WILL SEE POSITIVE
RESULTS IN TERMS YOU HAVE
THE EXECUTION OF THE TRUMP
FOREIGN POLICY.
>> Judge: YOU KNOW, WHAT
ABOUT WITH THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW, THE
NORTH KOREA SITUATION AND
THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW, HE
HAS GOT A STRONG CARD NOW,
ALLEN, AS IT RELATES TO
NORTH AND SOUTH KOREA?
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN VERY
INTERESTING.
WE KNOW THAT KIM JONG UN,
THE FIRST TIME HE EVER LEFT
NORTH KOREA WAS THIS WEEK TO
GO AND TRAVEL AND SIT DOWN
WITH XI JINPING IN CHINA.
CHINA AND NORTH KOREA
CHINA AND SORTH KOREA
CHINA AND SOUTH KOREA ARE
NERVOUS.
NOT ABOUT STRATEGIC
PATIENCE.
THEY KNOW THE PRESIDENT WILL
PUT PRESSURE ON CHINA AND
DEFINITELY PRESSURE ON NORTH
KOREA.
HE IS NOT BACKING DOWN.
AND SO THEY FIND THEMSELVES
IN A VERY PRECARIOUS
SITUATION.
AND I THINK XI JINPING WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT KIM JONG
UN IS VERY CLEAR AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT CHINA
CANNOT HAVE A KOREAN
PENINSULA THAT IS FRIENDLY
TO THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, JAPAN, OR OUR
ALLIES.
AS OPPOSED TO YOU CHINA.
CHINA CANNOT AFFORD FOR AN
IMPLOSION TO HAPPEN IN NORTH
KOREA WITH THE MASS
INFLUXION OF REFUGEES AND
ALSO THE LOSS OF THE HYDRO
ELECTRIC POWER PLANTS THAT
PROVIDE A LOT OF ELECTRICITY
FOR THOSE NORTHERN PROVINCES
IN CHINA.
>> Judge: INTERESTING.
BACK TO YOU, CONGRESSMAN
DESANTIS.
YOU KNOW, WE SAW KIM JONG UN
FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
PRESIDENT'S ADMINISTRATION,
FIRST 13, 14 MONTHS, YOU
KNOW, SETTING OFF THOSE
ICBMS AND, YOU KNOW, WITH
ALL THE NAME CALLING AND
SAYING WE WERE GOING TO GET
A BIRTHDAY PRESENT YOU KNOW
ON THE FOURTH OF JULY AND
ALL THAT OTHER STUFF.
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE IS
STARTING TO DRESS IN KIND OF
WESTERN GEAR, KIND OF.
HE IS MAKING TRIPS OUTSIDE
OF HIS COUNTRY.
WHAT'S DO YOU THINK HAS
CAUSED THIS MAN TO DO THIS
ABRUPT TURN AROUND?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S THE
PRESSURE THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION HAVE
PUT ON NORTH KOREA AND ON
CHINA TO A CERTAIN EXTENT.
AND WE HAVE MADE MORE
PROGRESS ON -- LOOK, WE ARE
A LONG WAY TO GO.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
PROBLEM.
KIM JONG UN IS AING THROUGH.
BUT, I
AIT, I
AING I
AINGTHROUGH -- IS A THUG.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE MORE PROGRESS IN 15
MONTHS THAN HIS PREDECESSORS
DID IN THE LAST QUARTER
CENTURY.
A LOT OF WORK LEFT TO DO,
BUT I THINK THE PRESIDENT
DESERVES CREDIT THAT WE'RE
ON THE BRINK OF POTENTIALLY
FINALLY GETTING SOME GOOD
RESOLUTION HERE.
>> Judge: VERY QUICKLY
FINALLY, ALLEN, THE WHOLE
IDEA WITHOUT THE RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATS HERE, WE ARE ALSO,
IN ADDITION TO THE COLD WARS
YOU MENTION YOU HAD,
ENTERING A NEW PERIOD WHERE
THERE CAN BE CONTINUING
CYBER ATTACKS.
YOU DON'T REALLY NEED TO BE
YOU KNOW, THEY CALL THEM
HYBRID WARFARE, HYBRID
ATTACKS.
THAT'S CERTAINLY A
POTENTIAL, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S THAT NEW DIMENSION
YOU HAVE WARFARE.
WE SEE THAT FROM CHINA AND
RUSSIA AND NORTH KOREA.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
CRITICAL THINGS WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SITS DOWN WITH KIM
JONG UN TO GET THEM TO
CURTAIL THEIR CYBER WARFARE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR
AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS AS WELL
AS HE NEEDS TO EXPRESS THAT
TO CHINA.
WITHOUT A DOUBT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE GOT TO